Investors see thousands
of deals every year and
they are in a place where they can
really select the ones that they feel
close affinity with, believe in and
want to go with going forward.
So, for
them it's really about a matter of fit.
At a very high level,
I think they look at three categories.
The first category, the team.
They look at the team and they want
to be in a place where they invest in
people that they say, hey I want
to work with this entrepreneur for
the next five to seven years and beyond.
So do they have good
chemistry with the person?
Do they think they're the right
team to push the startup forward?
The second category they
look at is the market.
Is the market opportunity big?
Is this something really
worth going after?
Is there a big problem to be solved
here and do I think there's a good match
between the team and the market
opportunity they're going after?
And the third item is the product or the
technology of what the team has done so
far to actually showcase that there's
a chance they'll exceed on their vision.
So those three things and
in each place the team, the market,
the product, investors look at a slew
of things and sometimes they decide
not to invest because they think
the market is not big enough or
the team is great but
maybe don't have the expertise.
Maybe the product is too early.
And they want to see more proof points,
but
those are the three big buckets of
items I think most investors look at.